Hace unos años, les envié el siguiente correo electrónico:
"Queridos hermanos, espero que se encuentren bien.
Les escribo para informarles
que me saldré de la maestría en ingeniería
para estudiar música a tiempo completo.
Lo único que les pido es que no se preocupen por mí".
El primero en responder
me apoyaba pero estaba un poco escéptico.
Dijo: "Te deseo la mejor de las suertes.
Vas a necesitarla".
(Risas)
Mi otro hermano fue un poco más escéptico.
Me dijo: "¡No lo hagas!
O será el peor error de tu vida.
Encuentra una carrera de verdad".
(Risas)
Bueno, mis otros hermanos estaban tan entusiasmados con mi decisión
que ni siquiera respondieron.
(Risas)
Sé que el escepticismo de mis hermanos
no es algo que deba importarme.
Ellos estaban preocupados.
Pensaron que sería difícil ser artista,
que sería un reto.
Y, ¿saben qué? Tenían razón.
Es un gran reto ser artista a tiempo completo.
Tengo muchos amigos que necesitan un segundo empleo,
un plan B para cubrir sus gastos,
pero a veces ese plan B se convierte en plan A.
Y no nos pasa solo a mis amigos y a mí.
Según la Oficina del Censo de EE.UU., solo el 10 % de los graduados en arte
consigue empleo a tiempo completo como artista.
El otro 90 % cambia de carrera,
trabaja en mercadotecnia, ventas, educación y otros campos.
Pero esto no es nuevo, ¿cierto?
Casi damos por hecho que un artista se las ve difíciles.
Pero, ¿por qué lo damos por hecho?
Leí un artículo en el "HuffPost"
que decía que hace cuatro años, la Unión Europea
comenzó la iniciativa de financiación de las artes más grande del mundo.
"Europa creativa" dará USD 2400 millones
a más de 300 000 artistas.
En contraste, el presupuesto de EE.UU. para el Fondo Nacional de las Artes,
el único proveedor de fondos para las artes en EE.UU.,
es de solo USD 146 millones.
Poniendo las cosas en perspectiva,
el presupuesto de EE.UU. solo para las bandas de marcha militares
es de casi el doble de todo el fondo nacional de las artes.
Otra imagen sorprendente viene de Brandan McMahon en el "HuffPost"
cuando dice que de un presupuesto de un billón de dólares
para gastos militares y de defensa,
si solo el 0,05 % fuera otorgado a las artes,
podríamos pagar 20 orquestas sinfónicas a tiempo completo
en USD 20 millones cada una,
y darle a más de 80 000 artistas
un salario anual de USD 50 000 a cada uno.
Si eso es solo el 0,05 %,
imaginen lo que se podría hacer con un porcentaje completo.
Sé que vivimos en una sociedad capitalista,
y las ganancias importan mucho.
Así que veámoslo desde una perspectiva financiera, ¿está bien?
La industria no lucrativa de las artes de EE.UU.
genera más de USD 166 000 millones en actividad económica,
da empleo a 5,7 millones de personas
y tiene un retorno de USD 12 600 millones
en ingresos fiscales.
Esto solo desde la perspectiva financiera.
Todos sabemos que las artes son mucho más que un mero valor económico.
Las artes le dan sentido a la vida.
Son el espíritu de nuestra cultura.
Unen a la gente y fomentan la creatividad
y la cohesión social.
Pero si las artes contribuyen tanto a nuestra economía,
¿entonces por qué aún se invierte tan poco en ellas y en los artistas?
¿Por qué más del 80 % de nuestras escuelas en el país
aún sufren reducciones monetarias en programas de educación para las artes?
¿Es que acaso aún no entendemos el valor de las artes y los artistas?
Creo que el sistema es defectuoso y está lejos de ser justo,
y quiero ayudar a cambiar eso.
Quiero vivir en una sociedad
donde se valore más a los artistas
y donde haya más apoyo cultural y financiero
para que puedan enfocarse en crear arte en vez de tener que conducir en Uber
o de tener trabajos corporativos que preferirían no tomar.
Hay otras fuentes de ingresos para los artistas, no obstante.
Hay fundaciones privadas,
becas y patrocinadores que otorgan dinero,
pero una gran mayoría de artistas no saben de esas oportunidades.
Por una parte, tenemos instituciones y gente con dinero.
Por otra parte, tenemos artistas en busca de financiamiento.
Pero los artistas no saben de la gente con dinero,
y la gente con dinero no siempre sabe
de los artistas que existen.
Por esta razón estoy muy emocionado por compartirles "Grantpa",
una plataforma en línea que usa tecnología
para que los artistas busquen becas y oportunidades de financiamiento
de forma fácil, rápida y menos intimidante.
"Grantpa" es solo un paso para resolver el problema
de la desigualdad financiera.
Pero necesitamos trabajar colectivamente desde varios frentes
para revaluar nuestra visión de los artistas en la sociedad.
¿Vemos a las artes como una necesidad o un lujo?
¿Comprendemos lo que ocurre en la vida diaria de un artista,
o creemos que sin importar cuánto luchen los artistas
deben ser felices simplemente porque hacen lo que les apasiona?
En unos años, planeo enviarles a mis hermanos el siguiente correo:
"Queridos hermanos, espero que se encuentren bien.
Les escribo para decirles que me va muy bien a mí
y también a cientos de artistas,
cada vez somos más valorados cultural y financieramente
y obtenemos suficientes fondos para enfocarnos en nuestro oficio
y poder crear más arte.
Agradezco todo su apoyo.
No lo hubiera logrado sin Uds."
Gracias.
(Aplausos)